the vakrama Swami helped himself the
most by doing well as an unknown
candidate Mike Pence slightly exceeded
expectations which were low Ron DeSantis
met expectations which were moderate
Chris Christie lobbed a few zingers but
they didn't land nearly as well as they
did last time among the lower polling
candidates Nikki Haley and Tim Scott
also met expectations and also did not
move the needle among the barely polling
candidates former Arkansas governor ASA
Hutchinson exceeded expectations and
soft on abortion Doug burgum proved
himself to be the single worst candidate
in the race by virtually every measure
and also somehow perhaps the most
likable they all did fine not one of the
candidates managed to break out in such
a way that would threaten The
front-runner Who currently leads his
most popular rival by more than 40
points